[Music]
today we're gonna talk about from
systrace to safety net android game
development case studies my name is
Chris Foley I'm a developer advocate
working with games here at Google and
today I'm joined on stage by Damian
Maybin who is a game engine engineer
from supercell and today I wanted to
talk about a few things it's not just
one topic but it's actually a few topics
about experiences that some of the
partners that we've worked with have had
in android game development and some of
the topics that we'll be covering today
will be systrace then we'll also be
talking about instant games and thirdly
we'll be going over a few case studies
and examples of how developers have used
app licensing and safety net attestation
API in order to safeguard their game so
first of all wanted to talk a little bit
about frame pacing and using systrace to
fix some issues that that supercell had
with their game brawl stars so up here
is Damian and Damian will be happy to
walk through us what they did with frame
pacing and/or fixing the frame pacing
with systrace and I'll hand it over to
him and he could start over right now
and I think there we go hey everyone I'm
Damian okay you might know it supercell
we have different teams that are fairly
autonomous and I work in the game engine
team so I am trying to help games team
focus on what they do best making the
game I'm trying to deal with like
platform issues or like technical issues
and one of them is input latency Anand
rate has been quite quite big
let's like while investigating input
latency when topic that came very
quickly is frame spacing so let's talk a
little bit about frame pacing it's just
a very quick intro before we do more
technical explanation so here you see
the yellow line is the time line in the
game and the green bar are the vsync
when the display actually refresh the
image and what what happened in many
games is the game is going to draw one
frame frame number one here and at the
end it's going to put it that that bar
is going to show the number of buffer
being queued for display so after the
ring frame number one is going to be
include for displayed and hopefully it's
going to get displayed at the next visit
here while while it's waiting for the
first frame to be displayed it's going
to draw a second frame which will get an
queued when it's finished drawing and
the game is not idle so it's going to
start during the third frame which an
Android will also get uncute because
Android allows ripple buffering so right
now we have two buffering the queue
waiting to be displayed and when the
fare currently displayed to the user at
the next waiting frame number two is
going to get displayed sorry
that's an interesting bit actually what
should happen is that you should start
during frame number four there however
it's going to get delayed until after
the vsync because you cannot acquire one
more buffer Android doesn't allow it
it's only triple buffering so after the
vsync frame number two is being
displayed frame buffer sorry frame
number three is still in the queue and
you can start draw frame number four
because you can equate your one buffer
at the end of the Ring frame number four
it's going to get an queued and you are
in a constant state of triple buffering
right now so the next frame is going to
be drawn after the vsync and you are
going to incur it and you are in a
constant state of triple buffering I
guess the reason why it's bad is when
you start considering inputs and the
user feeling of Latins
between when the user touched the screen
on do something on when it happened on
the screen so let's overlay on that
these yellow orange bar this orange bar
represent the time when Android tell us
something some input happened it's
actually tightly coupled with everything
so it happened a little bit after the
Java sync and if you look at the first
image and the first buffer and the ones
the draw one
well the input happen after the drone
has started so you can imagine the game
cannot really handle the input right
there so the game is actually going to
consume the input only next frame which
will then be rendered during that frame
which will be uncured which will be
consumed only in the next vessel so here
you are looking at a latency of one full
Vissing plus maybe 10 milliseconds which
is twenty six milliseconds latency it
wouldn't be terribly bad but if you look
at the case where the game is triple
buffering for example this one you start
seeing that between the time where you
receive the input and the time where it
is uncute there is maybe around 18
milliseconds roughly there but it's
uncured it's not the next buffer to be
displayed it's actually the third the
second one so you are looking at a whole
end-to-end latency around 40
milliseconds which start being
noticeable as players especially when
you look at a fast-paced action game
like roll star so what can we do well
let's take a look first at sorry can we
switch to the to the laptop please hi
let's take a look quickly at systrace so
when I was investigating this issue
sorry give me one second okay when I was
investigating this issue one thing I was
better
one thing I took really right away is a
systrace so from far away it looks
slightly scary I I'm going to try and
explain a bit what's happening there
okay so here at the top you can see the
CPU usage which you can see have some
spike on the bottom line that is pretty
constant there we can see details about
what's happening on each core but we
don't care too much about it
and then there is too is too interesting
between systrace the first one is
something called surface flinger you can
see the name there that's a non right
process that is responsible for
composing is the final image drawn on
the screen of your device so if you use
a normal app you will see that most of
the time you have the UI of the app but
you also have the notification bar at
the top on some of their element on the
screen so sister a surface flinger is
the one that takes a notification bar
the image of the app put both of them
together on this plate on the screen so
we are going to look into a bit of the
detail of systrace later and at the
bottom here we have come the super cell
that brawl star which is the game i was
profiling there okay let's go back to
systrace a little bit and let's zoom a
little bit so the cool part of this
trace tool if you open it in Chrome or
whatever you can navigate it the same
way you navigate in a game so W&S lets
you zoom in and out and a on D let you
go left and right which is convenient
okay let's take a look here so the first
thing to notice is this big grey on
white band our one frame D being
displayed on the screen so if you try to
measure each of these is 16 milliseconds
right it's running at 60 fps so yeah
and in surface flinger there is one line
here
surfaceview term the supercell which is
all the buffers that are being and
queued for rendering so if I click on
this one for example you can see there
is a value of 2 which means there is two
buffer in the queue if you look at here
there is one buffer in the queue which
you can guess means we are triple
buffering to buffer in the queue on when
displayed to the user which is pretty
bad it's the worst case I was explaining
earlier okay and if we look a little bit
more in surface flinger you can see at
the end of that vsync here there is a
whole lot of things that are happening
in in the UI thread so this whole lot of
things is what I was explaining it's if
we zoom a lot we can see do composition
here it's taking the different buffer
being displayed in the device and I'm
doing the composition to draw it on the
screen there is an interesting bit about
it if you look at that vsync here you
can see that our count of buffer in the
queue drop a little bit after the vsync
like about 500 microseconds the
interesting bit is naively when I looked
at it the first time I would believe
that drop would happen at the same time
as the vsync it's really interesting
because what it means is that that
buffer here is consumed by the UI thread
about there when it's written I play
your buffer it's later being composed
here which means it's only going to be
drawn there we will see why it's really
important a little bit later but on
Android what happened is instead of
consuming that buffer
sorry instead of consuming that the fare
here in order to draw it on the screen
it's consuming it here in order to draw
it there which which have a small impact
on and how latency work but I am going
to come back to it later it's just
interesting to notice that the hardware
composition happen so much earlier than
the servicing okay now let's take a look
at the game that's that the current game
that is currently live if we if we
looked at it you can see our game there
with our opengl thread and you see our
frame that is being drawn under all
frames there one thing that I discovered
is at the top you can see a scene line
that is either green or red they're red
these meanings that our thread is
slipping I'm not doing any work and
green is meaning we are actually doing
some stuff so you can see the this
undraw frame is actually in a sleep
State for a long while like 6.5
milliseconds and I would wondering
what's happening there and what's
happening is that it's not able to draw
because we are in that state of triple
buffering so we cannot acquire one more
buffer
okay enough talk about the current state
let's look at how it is after we did
some fixes and the frame pacing that's a
trace that is taken after we did some
fixes the first thing that is
interesting to notice is from far away
if you look at the surface flinger for
the surface view there is no more triple
buffering we are constantly in a state
of double buffering here we have one
buffer in the queue and then 0 100 0 so
we are constantly double buffering okay
as I was saying earlier that frame being
consumed here is being displayed at that
visit now let's take a look at what are
the input being used to draw that frame
because that's really what matter here
to reduce input latency so let me
highlight that moment where we include
one buffer and looked down in the game
so in that trace I did a little bit of
information about what's happening in
the game so you can see that at that
time we are slapping buffer that the
fare being swept is being drawn there
and the logic of the game is being
executed in the game update here the
interesting bit is if I keep zooming a
bit the game update here is using the
inputs that are delivered at that point
here so between that moment sorry
between that moment when the frame was
being drawn when it has been queued
sorry okay
so it has been queued here it has been
DQ'd there it will be rendered here on
the screen we are at about 32
milliseconds latency for the inputs
which is pretty much the best at least I
could I could find if we look back at
the previous game and we try to look at
the same number okay here we have triple
buffering so let's take a look at this
one we have we we have our on draw frame
happening here which is actually using
the input being delivered the previous
frame which happened around here and
then if I look at the queue it's being
DQ'd this buffer that is enqueued there
at the top is not the one being DQ'd
there it's the one being the queued at
the next frame which is actually being
rendered here so if I look at the
overall input latency we were looking at
something around one too many
around 47 milliseconds so we dropped
about one frame of latency let's take a
look at how it looks in the game in the
end because well that's what player
experience is right I made a small video
I'm not really good at editing video so
it's not my primary skill I did the best
so if you look very carefully it's
really clear obvious right now joking
I have a frame-by-frame thing happening
okay so look at the on the left here we
have our virtual joystick and there that
white circle is where the finger is or
pretty much it's actually displaying
we're on the rate sync the finger is so
I am going to put my mouse and that
white circle and I'm going to move
forward by one frame so you can see my
mouse is still not and there's of the
virtual joystick if I move by one frame
more now I have the virtual joystick
under my mouse which means that I have
to frame latency between the user input
and the game reacting to it now if you
look at the right yeah
if you look here for example you have
the that's after the fix so you have the
user finger being here and if I move by
one frame like the vercharged oh stick
is on it which means we have one frame
later on see in the display between the
user input and the display on the screen
it's also interesting if I move a little
bit forward or backward in time actually
sorry if you look here the distance
between the joystick and the finger is
quite big if you look at this one the
distance is quite quite a lot shorter
sorry yeah it's quite a tad shorter
which means that like that's also
translate into the the latency felt by
the user
yes that the result of the input latency
fix one frame less okay can we switch
back to the slide please we hop on back
to the yeah thank you oh yeah so that's
about it for my part and systrace and
dark art of systrace on how to
understand it if you have any question I
am happy to chat after the talk I am
handing it back to Chris cool there you
actually did that water cool Thank You
Damian yeah yes this trace it's it can
be a little bit frightening at first but
it's a really powerful tool for really
optimizing the performance of your game
so it's all available I would encourage
looking into it if that's something that
you're really interested in and really
making your game run smoother and it
really better
so moving on we're gonna move into
something a little more high-level and
this will be instant game referral
tracking so they first talked a little
bit about why we would want to have
instant games anyways so the traditional
game install flow looks something like
this there's a user acquisition event
like somebody clicks on an ad they click
on it takes them to the Play Store nice
big banner at the top install and this
is great the player wants to try and
play your game the idea is they try it
they find it really exciting and they
want a player or they go into and and
play right but now they have to install
now that's actually a lot of friction
right there you know could be up to a
100 megabyte download there and maybe
they're on not on Wi-Fi maybe on mobiles
somewhere and if you're a game developer
I'm sure you all really know that really
the end result is that often just
getting an install can be the challenge
you know that once they play the game
they'll love it but you can't even get
to that point
so this is where instant games come in
so starting through your user
acquisition flow imagine you instead
click and instead of having to go to a
store it just immediately goes to well
this screen right here which is Google
Play Instant installing a game right
there and they try of a demo version of
the game this is an instant game that
they can play right away there's no
install they're immediately into the
gameplay experience and you can use this
use this moment to really sell your game
to your player and in fact here on the
top you there's a little button it's
hard to read here but it says install
now and the instant game is the is the
is where you prompt the player to
actually install the game but this is
after they've had a chance to really
experience it and really enjoy the game
and really this is why you've made the
game in the first place once they
actually decide that they want to try it
then you do the install then you
actually prompt them the game begins to
download but you know it doesn't matter
so much at this point because you've
already gotten the player involved and
they're already really committed to it
now as I'm talking about this this is
obviously about optimizing user
acquisition and I'm sure that you all
know if you've done any user acquisition
that a key part of this is knowing your
analytics knowing your metrics how
effective are your different ad
campaigns knowing where your sources of
those clicks are but the issue is that
when you if you have an instant game
just naively the game will not know
where that source is because there's
that intervening step and so if you look
at the game from its point of view it
doesn't know where the source is however
there's a way to fix this and that is
forwarding the referral from the instant
game so as it turns out the instant game
gets the same referral information that
a regular game install would so the
problem or really the issue is at that
point you just have to collect that data
and somehow get that to the full game
and this is how it's done so you first
buy you first collect the referral data
by adding the
code to the instant games on create and
you can see we get the intent you know
we do a little processing about it then
at the bottom you pull the parameters
out of the rand then here they even add
a extra parameter on to that which is
from IG from instant game equals true
then you then it include this referral
data as an additional parameter for in
show install prompt which is the part in
the instant game where you actually are
prompting the user will do obviously
install the full game and then the full
game will get that get those parameters
and then can use those to send those on
and track your user acquisition referral
information so this is how it works in
real life so forwarding instant game
referral strings let's say we have ad
campaign number two and here I have it
so say somebody in Columbia here clicks
on an ad for your game now the referral
link will look something like this this
is obviously a generic one but a year
there's your link to the store now at
the bottom you have your referral source
and it's a little bit URL encoded but it
says source will equal the ad campaign -
that's where the source came from and
then down at the bottom is launch equals
true which tells the instant game to
immediately start installing and
downloading the game which is what you
want lowers the amount of friction for
getting into the game now in the instant
game there's the ship code I just showed
you that pulls the parameter out then at
the bottom you show the install prompt
now the full game now has the full
information it has the source ad
campaign - and there's even our
additional source which is from instant
games equals true now you have even more
information about your acquisition and
lastly you know then of course you send
that back to your own servers your own
analytics and this is how you can
actually see the full impact of your ad
campaign and with instant games
so on to my last topic today which is
talking about ensuring the integrity of
your game so I'm sure you're all aware
asking game developers that you want
people to play your game that's great
but when you have a game out there it's
also going to attract bad actors people
who want to cheat people who want to
hack the game maybe people who want to
maybe take advantage of other players or
maybe hurt their experience you know
there's lots of different areas out
there and these all come in from
different modes of attack which are like
modded apks you know or pirated apks or
emulators out there which are not bad in
themselves obviously but you know they
can be used in various various attempts
to you have rooted devices once again
you know not bad in itself but can be
used to launch various attacks onto the
game such as memory attacks and so if
you're thinking about how do I know how
do I keep my game safe how do I protect
the integrity how do I protect my player
base from having our ecosystem hacked in
some way and it really boils down to two
parts first of all can the binary be
trusted in particular did the binary
come from somewhere that I trust is it
from a known source and the second part
is can the device itself be trusted
because obviously if you're just
listening to the app itself if you're
the a PK and the apk says hey I'm great
I came from a great place but you don't
own the device and the device might be
hacked or modified in some way that
could change that so you want to make
sure that the device is okay as well so
for the first part can the binary be
trusted there is a Pleiss insane and for
the second part can the device be
trusted there's the safety net
attestation API and these two parts work
together to help ensure the integrity of
your game and let me talk a little bit
more about how this is a licensing works
like this say you have a game and you
want to know did this game was this apk
downloaded from
Playstore so the game at startup you're
launching it's doing all it's set up in
initialization and at this point it
calls the app licensing API and check
access which reaches out to the license
verification server for play and says
does the Google user here or does the
play user have they ever downloaded this
game from the store
assuming it says yes then the returns
with a valid license which triggers the
license checker callback and the player
is allowed into the game likewise
suppose they don't have a license
suppose they haven't downloaded the apk
from Play Store maybe they side loaded
it somewhere maybe was distributed
somewhere else then it returns with no
license which comes back to the license
checker callback and you have a
mechanism of blocking the keeping the
player out of the game the second thing
is second safety net integrity each
check and this is a little bit more
complicated as I said you don't really
want to trust anything on the device if
you're checking to see if the device
itself has been compromised so this has
to be initialized from the back end so
in this case here we out brawl stars in
their supercell back end and that
initializes initiates the check it does
that by sending a nonce a small unique
ID that you're going to associate with
this request all the way through this
process you'll get to that why in a
second the back end sends a nonce to the
game the game at this point
uses that nonce adds it onto the API
call which goes to the safety net s2
attestation API on the device which then
forwards that back on to the Google
antah station API back-end now this
back-end has a lot of different signals
and ways of checking if the device
itself has been compromised or if it's
it hasn't been certified if it is not
certified or if it is certified and it
uses all these different signals to
basically return back to you it says
this device is good
or maybe it isn't so good whatever that
response is gets sent back to the safety
net assay Station API which then comes
back to the game itself for to back onto
the back end now the back end here is
going to then check to see whether or
not this this is where you actually
you're checking the response here like I
said you don't want to chest trust the
device just yet so if you have a Valadez
sensation and the nonce manses now the
reason you have that nonce is to protect
against replay attacks because there
could be a hack for example that takes a
valid attestation and responds back and
says hey where everything's good even
though it isn't however they won't have
the correct nonce that you have attached
for that and that's is why you initiate
that from the back end you will also
want to check few other things like time
stamps you know just in case something
else is there's a few other checks that
you put into there but assuming
everything works out says good let's the
player into the game so this is how
safety net integrity check works so how
does this work in the real life and how
can you use this to try your game so I
have a couple interesting cases here the
first is from Rovio now Rovio is a game
named Angry Birds 2 which maybe you've
heard of
now obviously Angry Birds 2 huge game
global worldwide and it also has a
global leader board now you're thinking
is a popular game and it has a
leaderboard that everyone in the world
to see has wants to see there are going
to be a lot of attacks on this
leaderboard because a lot of people want
to cheat and get their name on the top
of that leaderboard so Rovio was seeing
a lot of attacks coming in and there
were two main ways of attacking the
leaderboard that they saw the first was
tampered a be case modified apks
somewhere that people were side loading
and the second one was a memory attack
and accessed to the memory of the game
now this is only possible on a rooted
device so this is a perfect use case for
safety net which is checking to see if
the device has been rooted or not
because if it's been rooted then you
can't really trust to see it try
that the device is really as it always
was maybe there was a custom ROM or
something else so Rovio in implemented
safety net add a station API and the
results were pretty good for them what
they saw was first of all right off the
top forty percent fewer hack attempts on
their leaderboard I mean if you think
about it that's 40% fewer attacks you
have to defend against it's a much more
safer environment for their game it's
less that they have to work on whoops
sorry click a little bit it helps with
their resource management as far as
managing the game it's less effort for
protecting the game and then second of
all what they saw were there was a
higher degree of spenders in their top
leaderboard which if you think about
this makes sense and this is really what
they wanted to see because you don't
want to see hackers in the top of the
leaderboard you don't want to see people
who are there you know don't really care
about the game they just want to show
off like hey I'm great at this instead
the leaderboard was actually showing
real players people who were really
committed and dedicated to the game
those are the ones that you would expect
to actually be on the leaderboard and
that's actually what Rovio got so as a
result it really helped the game and
help their community help their
leaderboard or help the the ecosystem of
their game they were very very happy
with the results and then finally for
the last case I wanted to talk about
today which is reducing beta leakage
with app licensing and safety net
together now first of all what is beta
leakage so some people call it beta some
call it a soft launch but the idea is
before you do your full launch before
you gave it out to they give your game
out to the rest of the world you might
want to try a limited release a soft
launch where you have a fewer maybe a
few territories where people are trying
out the game you start getting feedback
on it you start getting some information
about the resources used by the game
maybe how many servers you need for it
and so on and kind of see if the game is
actually working like you think so
that's what your beta is but you want to
keep it limited you don't want it
everyone out there because your game
wellit's this isn't really ready for the
full world
but beta leakage is when that doesn't
happen where instead of having a few
territories playing the game now you
have people from everywhere playing the
game and this can be really bad for your
game management because now all of your
projections on how much server usage or
the demographics of your users or
therefore say the actions or the
behavior of your audience are going to
be completely out of whack from what you
may have expected to begin with and this
is a real problem because especially for
games that are very very very popular
where really highly anticipated games
you get a lot of people who might want
to get that apk even if they're not in
one of those territories where they're
allowed to and in fact one of our
partners that we worked with saw a real
issue with this so they saw in our past
a stir Android soft launches that 90% of
their beta users came from non beta
countries because they're able to see
where these players were playing
normally but in this case now when they
want to play the beta son later and
they're able to play even though they're
not in that place and the reason for
this is that well Android is really open
is that's very cool I mean that's one of
the best things about the platform and
sharing apks is also quite
straightforward you can pull an apk you
can share it around distribute to your
friends and so on and maybe on different
forums and so really the challenge for
the game developer who wants to keep
their beta limited is how do you prevent
your soft launch from an into
unintentionally becoming a global launch
and this is where app licensing comes in
and safety net so as I mentioned sharing
outside of beta regions typically
happens via sharing apks now in this
beta only the people that were in those
few beta countries could actually
legitimately download the apk from the
Play Store so if you had the apk and
you're not from a beta country you would
not have a valid license for it as a
result app licensing which ensures that
that apk actually came from the Play
Store well that's the first thing you
want to use and that is how you can
prevent people from playing the playing
the game wear it in places where you've
made
we didn't intend now as I mentioned
safety net of course is needed to check
your device integrity make sure that you
can trust that app licensing to begin
with now what was the results of this
well the developer we worked with on
this saw a huge reduction in their in
the number of non beta users they saw
50% reduction in the number of their
beta players who came from non beta
countries and 50% that's huge the
developer was really really really happy
about this and for me this was actually
the first time I'd seen a developer used
this for locking down their beta and I
think it's a really very interesting use
case so if you have a game that's coming
out and you're worried about maybe
keeping it only in a certain region this
is something I would actually take a
look at so finally just kind of recover
talk again about what we were what I
cover today so first of all we talked
about systrace and Damion was very
helpful on going through very in-depth
on how they use systrace to help fix
some of the frame facing it seriously
saw in Brawl stars next we talked about
instant game and how you can for your
referral information from the instant
game to the full game to really take
full advantage of the increased user
acquisition and that instant games
provides and then lastly we went over a
couple interesting use cases of using
app licensing and safety net to help
protect your game and really protect
your ecosystem against bad actors that
might be out there so with that I'd like
to conclude my talk and first of all I'd
like to give a huge thank out thanks to
super cell and Rovio for allowing me to
discuss their games and use some of
their images to help spice up my talk
and I'd also like to thank all of you
for sitting through my talk and
listening to me I hope it's been
instructive and I would encourage to
encourage you to look into these issues
on the place or on in the Android
documentation if you're interested thank
you very much
[Music]
you